Francis over to the guardian far beat
from me to color your responsible
wattage tiresome old U.S race grifter Al
Sharpton up too good to see that we're
remaining impartial assignment so Al
Sharpton warns that the UK could suffer
U.S style police brutality without deep
reform and he is on the eve of a two-day
visit to the UK he has said that
systemic racism and a culture of
policing that produces brutality must be
addressed and this is the problem when
you have people from the United States
commenting on things that they know
relatively little to nothing about we do
not have the same problems when it comes
to police brutality that they have in
the United States because we do not have
and this is the most important thing
that people miss all the time we do not
carry guns in this country they don't
generally I mean there are occasional
shootings but they have to be
specifically accorded don't they to the
to the officers of course of course I do
but the vast majority of citizens in
this country don't carry guns as well
yeah yeah so because so when in the
United States when there is a stop in
search immediately things are heightened
because the police officer doesn't know
if the citizen is carrying a gun so
automatically it's a high stakes game
whereas in this country the stakes are
much lower because nobody very few
people carry guns it's presumed to be
and of course Sharpton is coming off the
back of having given an address at the
funeral of uh Tire Nichols who's the
most recent appalling outrage but this
was committed by five black police
officers well exactly and this was
committed by five black police officers
and it was an awful incident like you
said let's just make that absolutely
clear and we all hope that those those
police officers get brought to Justice
and they get dealt with in the harshest
possible way because what happened was
awful but the problem is is what happens
when you get U.S style identity politics
imported wholesale into this country and
and then just it digested when the
reality is it's two different countries
two different police forces two
completely different cultures absolutely
right and I'm afraid to say I don't
think Al Sharpton is going to be alive
to those nuances never mind Steve
[Music]